Matt Walsh is a writer for the daily
wire who I think will be helpful as we
discuss this
legislation and its importance Matt
would you please come up here and say a
few words and thank you for being in
Mississippi thank you
great well
I want to thank the governor and the
lawmakers here in Mississippi who have
done the right necessary Thing by
Banning the horrific medical abuse of
children
I'm extremely encouraged to not only see
this law being passed but to see the
national movement that we have been able
to build pushing back against the gender
ideology of Madness that has a
Stranglehold on our society
and on our children for far too long
the reality is that this is not a
difficult issue as the governor's
already covered it's quite
straightforward in fact if we lived in a
sane Society run by sane people we would
all be able to agree on this point the
question of whether it's ever okay to
castrate and sterilize and mutilate a
child
um would be answered in one loud and
unified voice saying without hesitation
not only no but hell no
that is how all normal Common Sense
decent Americans answer the question and
they don't have to think about it
but sadly many of the people hold power
in this country who run our institutions
do not pass this basic test of human
decency
these vultures have lined up to Feast on
and profit from the confusion of
innocent kids
confusion that these same vultures have
intentionally fostered in the minds of
our youth
they create the identity crisis and then
they monetize it
these kids are put on so-called puberty
blockers to chemically castrate them
drugs that by the way have been given to
sex offenders to chemically castrate
them and now we give them to kids
off-brand Cancer drugs that we're giving
to children
they're given cross-sex hormones which
have irreversible and permanent effects
and before the age of 18 many kids will
undergo surgery such as double
mastectomies
now the kids cannot choose any of this
they cannot consent to it they can't
understand what they're doing or what
the long-term
effects or even short-term effects are
going to be
you know I often make the same point the
governor just made and it's an important
point that many of the people who
support and advocate for this Butchery
are not petitioning
to lower the drinking age
uh you don't hear them calling for laws
to make sure that kids have access to
Tobacco or firearms
they aren't Marching In the Street
demanding that 13 year olds should be
able to get tattoos or open credit card
accounts or take out mortgages
in all of these cases they recognize
that minors have neither the maturity
nor the powers of discernment nor the
psychological nor neurological formation
required to make these sorts of choices
and yet these gender ideology Advocates
want us to believe
that the child who can't be trusted with
a can of beer
or with a credit card
should be trusted to permanently
transition into a different gender
it's Madness it is incoherent
and all the more incoherent when you
consider that nobody nobody actually can
transition into a different gender
that's not physically possible it's not
medically possible the doctors are lying
to confused people
so the very fact the very fact that a
child desires to do such a thing in in
the first place is proof in itself that
she isn't thinking clearly and doesn't
understand what she's saying or what she
claims to want
which is not unusual for children that's
why they're children
we simply cannot allow this evil to
continue we cannot tolerate it we who
are decent and rational people we who
love our children we who recognize basic
truths
and one of the most basic truths is that
children who are confused about their
identity need guidance and love and
clarity
they don't need hormone injections and
scalpels
they need and deserve to be protected
from the child abusing quacks and
soulless goblins who wish to exploit
their confusion for their own financial
gain
that's why we need this law
our kids cannot protect themselves they
cannot protect themselves we need to do
it that's our job as adults
and everybody who's remained silent on
this issue is culpable in what is
happening to our kids many members of
the media who have not
demonstrated the slightest bit of
skepticism as the medical establishment
has just told us over the years
that it's life-saving care to castrate a
child and you have members the majority
of the media that just goes along with
that doesn't ask one skeptical question
about it
all culpableness
that's why we need to protect our kids
we can and we must and now Mississippi
has
and finally I would only uh say to any
other state that hasn't gotten on board
with protecting kids that it's time to
get on board
okay it's time to get on board it's time
to do the right thing
it's way past time
we have to act now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]